well I'm delighted as I'm joined now by
the mayor of London City Khan Mr Mayor
good to see you
it's been too long because I'm just only
sorry we're not doing this in person but
it's lovely to be with you again
although the first time on your on your
new show well it's not you anymore is it
well it's not you and you have resisted
my advances for quite some time so
what's made you finally succumb
well I think to be fair we were trying
to hook something up a few weeks ago but
you were very busy doing stuff uh
overseas and I'm just really sorry it's
taken so long hopefully next time I'll
be in person well
uh we've always I think had a robust
exchange of views over the years this
start with the obvious subject which is
your campaign about air quality in
London I want to preface this part of
the interview by saying that I have gone
through a quite uh well interesting
journey I think about pollution in
London so I thought I had a big issue
with hay fever for quite a few years and
eventually had a lot of tests done
revealed no allergies at all and then
had a local chemist who said to me I
think it may be pollution is it worse
when you come back from overseas I went
actually yes it is and it was knocking
me out for like half a day every week
and he recommended getting some air
purifiers and getting an air quality app
and not going out too much when it was
very high I did both those things I've
got four purifiers in my house now 80
pounds each and it's completely
transformed my health I'm a different
human being in the last eight months to
what I'd been like in the previous few
years I then did some digging into the
borough I live in Kensington and Chelsea
and discovered to my horror that is one
of the worst places in the country for
air pollution and that there's a lot of
people who die from pollution related
deaths in Kensington and Chelsea so I'm
I'm a convert to your cause I I believe
it is a real issue I've been through an
experience myself that's made me see the
benefit of having better quality air
albeit through uh purifiers but here's
the problem that I think you've
encountered it's a similar problem to
the just stop oil protests where I agree
with their calls but I don't agree with
the methodology and it seems to me that
your ule's scheme
albeit well-intentioned and I think we
all want to get to where you want to get
to an air quality but it's turned out to
be incredibly divisive you know this
very polarizing the polls actually show
us pretty split down the middle about
what people's views are perhaps if you
live in the outer part of London more
extremely against it than those who live
in the inner part of the of the city but
it is very divisive and it is very
controversial do you have any regrets
about the methodology
thank you for the thoughtful way you've
asked the question because I like you
were on a journey in 2014 uh 2015 I had
no idea uh about what you've discovered
either I was feeling out of breath when
I was playing football I was getting
tired very quickly I had some really bad
days where I was wheezing and coughing
and I'm like you reasonably well
informed I think I know a bit about uh
you know things like air pollution air
quality climate change but I have no
idea that this invisible thing we can't
see particularly matter and nitrogen
dark side is making us sick and so the
evidence in relation to the consequences
of air pollution uh you and I are living
out but also in our city around 4 000
people die prematurely because of air
pollution across our country according
to government figures not mine
government figures
between twenty eight thousand and thirty
six thousand and at least the children
having stunted lungs forever and adults
like you and I with a whole host of
health issues from asthma to cancer
dementia to heart disease but also
appears to answer your question directly
I've seen the evidence of the Euless in
central London where it exists and in
Illinois where it exists and I'll tell
you what I mean by that so we introduced
the Euros in central London and So
within a year at almost 50 reduction in
toxicity but also a third fewer children
with air pollution-related illnesses
being rushed to hospital uh a third
reduction we expanded it to Inner London
and we saw a further 20 reduction in air
pollution and children going to 1400
schools were breathing cleaner air let
me see the problem it's in outer London
that's the worst air the 10 boroughs
with the largest amount of premature
deaths are in outer London what we've
also seen is that 24 of the 30 GPS with
the worst number of patients is an
outline so that's the aim but what I've
tried to do also appears is to listen to
the genuine concerns and I recognize by
the way peers in relation to regret over
a number of years in outer London we
haven't got the good quality public
transport we've got in central London
and in London so more people are relying
on cars in outer London the good use uh
9 out of 10 cars now driving in outer
London are already compliant won't pay a
penny more but we'll see the benefits of
cleaning okay
I don't I don't want to get into arguing
about the merits of what you're trying
to do because I actually broadly agree
with you on the methodology it seems to
me here's your problem in a nutshell I
have an Aston Martin right a very
luxurious car I'm very lucky to have it
lucky to earn enough money to be able to
keep it up and you don't charge me a
penny to drive that around London as
much as I like because I'm Ole's
compatible but if I lived in in North
London in Wembley or somewhere and I was
a hard-working guy woman and you're
driving a van maybe for work and you
have to come into town every day and
you're already facing massive cost of
living uh extra costs for your family
you're struggling to feed your family
you're really feeling the pinch and now
suddenly you who really can't afford
just to get through the day as it is are
suddenly having to pay another 12 pounds
50 every day to you why am I being
spared just because I can afford to have
a more expensive u-less compatible car
and why are a large number of people who
are having to pay actually at the poorer
end of the spectrum of London society
that is where your Optics I think are
failing
so because your car is a U.S compliant
it means that you're off Euro 4 or
better what that means appears is when
you drive your car at your wife maybe
next to your daughter in the back
they're not breathing in Poison the same
way somebody driving a non-compliant car
is that's the first point the second
point is what we're doing is to support
the hard-working van driver you talked
about to support the low income family
you're talking about to support the
charity within minibus you may be
talking about we're giving financial
support to the tune of 160 million
pounds so a small van owner a small
business with a van like yours will now
receive uh support uh seven thousand
Pounds to get a ulyss compliant van you
don't need to by the way buy a electric
van if you've got a car you don't need
to buy an Aston Martin and the good news
is there are U.S compliant cars Vans and
many of us is available and so the
scrappage support we're given without
Penny of support from the government who
are giving support to cities around the
country with their clean air zones means
that person you're talking talking about
who I understand will be anxious will
have the support to make the transition
okay but I've heard all the phone names
and a lot of them are Furious they're
not just concerned about this they are
furious at what they see is a punitive
tax on the poorer people in the city and
also why are they being picked on us how
they see it my argument again about the
just stop oil campaign you've got to
bring people with you at the moment
you've got half of your city and you're
the mayor of the whole city you've got
half of the city up in arms about this
they're attacking the ulez machinery and
the streets which I don't support they
shouldn't be doing that there's a lot of
blind rage about this I've heard the
phone ends on the radio what are you
going to do about this growing anger
because you may be right in your cause I
believe you're right about trying to get
better air quality but you know that the
labor party are very concerned about it
I want to play you a little mashup of
what labor figures have been saying
about it
I don't think there's any doubt that
Euless was the reason that we lost the
by-election in Uxbridge and I have said
we should reflect on this including the
mayor I've spoken to him as you would
expect and so there will be that
reflection the cost is a problem and if
you look at who pays you less it tends
to be poorer families and smaller
businesses I'm afraid that the hard
truth is
a 12 pounds an hour or sorry 12 pounds a
day fee costs labor that by-election
there is a massive cost of living crisis
at the moment and and asking people to
Shell out thousands to buy a new vehicle
or pay 12.50 every day to to go on the
road is is is just a an expense to too
many
now these aren't Tories saying this this
is your own side they think that this is
an election liability how would you feel
if you go down this path you dig your
heels in as you're doing you keep going
but it ends up potentially becoming an
election deciding issue in the next year
or so whenever that general election may
come that the Tories use this as a
weapon to actually defeat you then labor
doesn't win power to do all the other
things it wants to do not least of which
including the environment
well let me respond if I may please
Pierce to the various points you've made
and deal with each of them so the first
point I'd make is you you very
generously and rightly said that in
central London uh people support Euless
and in inner London but there's some
concern in outer London I would argue
the reason why people in central London
and Inland and support policies because
they've seen it bedded in and they
realize it's not as bad as they said it
was going to be I I'll give you some
breaking news when I announced the
central London policy people were
against that as well initially until we
had a scrappage scheme and they saw the
benefits were far better than the
disbenefits and the point of making is
this when I began that Journey appears
only 44 44 of cars in the whole of
London were compliant so the majority
would have been losers and now that
figure in inner London is 97 of
compliance in outer London on an average
day a night out of 10 are compliant
that's the first point I would make with
respect the second point I would make is
in outer London there's been a lot of
misinformation but also some genuine
anxiety because people think they'll be
caught when in fact they won't be caught
and so the really good news is on an
average day in outer London a 9 out of
10 cars seen driving are already
compliant they don't pay a penny more
but see the benefits and because I've
been listening you played I can't see
but you played you know Care West and
other colleagues in the layer party
because I've been listening not just to
them but to londoners who want to see
better public transport four million
kilometers of new buses in outer London
a new super Loop bus in outer London
Elizabeth line extended to east and west
of London the DLR now extended but also
a scrappy scheme so every single
Londoner car owner motorcycle owner van
owner minibus owner who may be affected
now gets support but they're saying
they're not getting enough support and
my other question to you about that
would be why if the government has
helped out other cities up and down the
country why have they not helped you out
well I think I think this goes to the
core of the anger you're talking about
which is basically the government thinks
because of Uxbridge and ruislip that
actually tackling climate change
entitling air pollution uh are about
losers and so they've weaponized this as
an issue and so they're giving people
the impression around the country that
there's the U.S come into but I'm quite
clear what's right for London it may not
be right for Luton what's right for
Burman Zee may not be right for uh
Burnley and so what the government is
doing is weaponize this as an issue and
what I'm Keen to do is to listen to the
concerns people have and their genuine
concerns many of them and try and
address them but I say again this was a
difficult decision but I think it's a
vital one and the right one but are you
likely are you likely in view of the
pretty extreme reaction from half of
your people in London are you likely to
evolve this policy and reflect their
concerns
yeah we will always listen to londoners
so I'll give you just three examples in
January where to announce the policy is
because I listened to the consultation
people saying I'm a low-income family
I've got a small business employ less
than 10 people I'm a charity I'm
disabled so we gave support in January
to those people
in July I expanded the support to every
single family in London receiving what's
called child benefit that's about 800
000 people but you're right they were
still concerned which is why the first
week of August I said every single
person in London it doesn't matter how
much you earn uh you will get support in
relation to the subscriber scheme and
the reason why the government's not
giving London support they're giving
Birmingham support and Bristol support
and bath support is they think by
attacking londoners they may do better
at the general election so londoners are
pawns caught in this Crossfire what I
say to the government is you know grow
up work with me to support londoners
whether you're a family whether you're a
charity whether you're a business nobody
wins if people are dying prematurely
nobody wins if kids have stunted lungs
true but nobody wins if half of the
people in London hate you because they
think you're targeting the poorer
members of society over people like me
I've got to be
I've got to be frank peers you asked the
question at the top of the this
interview which is which was you know
why am I on this show I gotta be honest
one of the reasons I'm on this show is
because I recognize me and my voters you
know watch this show and I'm Keen to
talk to them through you peers and you
ask me the tough questions that they
that they ask me and I respond to uh as
well because I genuinely think those
people see the benefits of this policy
they'll come with me as they did in
central London as they did in England
but also appears I spent time on great
Almond Street speaking to kids with this
with stunted lungs I've met the doctors
treating kids of the children's evil in
a hospital I've met a bereaved mum I
myself listen would I have an asthma
attack I know what to do I take my pump
I take my tablets I'm in control it
imagine being a kid with an illness
that's preventable by tackling air
pollution air pollution is not
inevitable it's preventable
like I said at the start I I'm with you
about the the problem of air pollution
I've seen it myself I've seen it to my
own health so I'm with you on that I
just think that you've got to understand
I think the scale of concern I think you
probably do you've been there a long
time I think you understand a lot of
people are very angry about this and
hopefully there will be some compromises
to be here but let's move on to some
other stuff in the news today Jillian
Keegan the education secretary who many
people are very angry with because of
this crisis over schools being closed
because of the concrete that have been
used to build them and we're blaming the
government for not acting sooner she
responded like this off Mike in an
interview today today with ITV
does anyone ever say you know what
you've done a good job because everyone
else has sat on there and done nothing
no no signs of that no
do you feel this is a good moment Mr
Mayor to tell the education secretary
she's done an effing good job
I I've not seen that until just now
um
look I mean
and for those that don't know we had a
conversation before we went on air
that's you know so there's you can be
caught out with you know hot mic as they
call it but I think the problem the
problem is
I I mean the arrogance in relation to
you know thinking you should be going to
pat on the back I I spent Friday
speaking to really worried parents who
didn't know
whether their kids are going to school
on Monday whether they're to organize
child care my sister's a teacher as is
my sister-in-law they had no idea
whether their schools are affected I was
also at MP in 2010 lobbying Michael Gove
and the government saying for goodness
sake please don't cut the program you're
going to cut the buildings because the
future program that had balls had
announced and you know austerity has
consequences
to understand children are caught in the
crossfire because of government cuts for
the last 13 years and rather than asking
for a pat on the back she needs to be
spoken working night and day to make our
schools safe and it you know it is a
problem the fact that literally forget
our Public Services crumbling literally
our schools are crumbling yeah I
completely agree I thought it was
unbelievably arrogant and tone deaf uh
let's talk about women because she's a
woman
what is a woman Mr Mayor
well I asked that question known full
well that people may be watching this
who may have gendered dysphoria and may
you know have concerns in relation to
this issue it's going to be quite Direct
in relation to this so a woman when it
comes to biology insects is an adult
girl
but there are some women who may have
gender dysphoria and you know trans
women can also be women as well
for example about the issue of trans
women and women's sport which many
including me think is grotesquely unfair
look my starting point is dignity and
respect but it's a fact when you look at
the science
there is a massive advantage in relation
to some sports if you have been through
puberty for example as a boy man and
then you know change your gender uh then
so I think it's right that the sporting
authorities look at the science look at
the evidence because it's a massive
Advantage would you bet would you ban
try and swim in and have them compete in
either their own category or perhaps
against their biological sex
I think it depends on sport I'll give
you an example
um you know I suspect it may not impact
performance in relation to darts or
snooker uh I clearly would in relation
to the 100 meters so I think I think
each sporting Authority has gonna start
from the basis of you know dignity and
respect and protecting trans people but
then realize that in some sports there's
clearly a massive advantage in relation
to biology I mean it's become a
bizarrely a hot issue this many people
tripping up over trying to categorize
what woman is you you've defined what a
woman is which is good to see Kia star
must said that 99.9 I think he's up to
now of women don't have penises uh what
percentage do you think it is
I'm not going to apply percentage what I
do know peers is uh is you know why I'm
asking because most women watching would
say of course actually 100 100 of women
don't have penis I'm sure
look I was speaking to people who work
in the domestic violence sector a couple
of weeks ago and you know trans women
you know are on the receiving end
of domestic violence domestication you
see this is I've heard people try and
distract the conversation like this
I don't dispute that and I want I
absolutely to be clear I want trans
people to be treated with Humanity with
respect and with fairness and equality I
know you do my issue my issue comes
where trans rights start to subjugate
women's rights and I think that's what
the problem is
no I was going to say please forgive me
is that and those trans women who at the
receiving end of drastic violence you
know may have had a penis is the point I
was going to make but similarly I know
you know there are some there are some
places that are protected for single sex
brackets biology so so you know these
are complicated issues and that's why I
don't I don't want to be flipping it's
not it's really it's actually not that
complicated is it I mean I think if you
start from a position there are men and
women and then there are trans women and
trans men if you just articulated like
that there's not a problem it gets
complicated when people try and pretend
I think males or women
I think it's biology than this gender
isn't there and the point I was trying
to get across is is that you know that
I'm aware it's very difficult if you're
somebody who's trans you're going
through this and and you know so what
I'm trying to do is be sensitive to that
but recognizing as you've asked me to do
of some of the challenges when it comes
to sports particularly those Sports
where your sex does matter right you I
mean at City Hall you have a weird
series of rules have been laid down you
don't like gender specific phrases like
ladies and gentlemen to be used because
it may exclude non-binary people what if
what if somebody wants to be called a
lady or a gentleman you know British
Airways have done this too and I'm like
hang on when I get on a plane I actually
quite like to be called a gentleman
where are my rights to still be called a
gentleman
well I'm not sure about that oh well
about that being City Hall rule but I
can't tell you about myself
categorization okay
I I love days when I call a gentleman uh
you know but I think what may what it
may be is you know somebody may have
said friends or people or londoners I
don't know but no nothing's banned you
know you know often when people are
doing speeches that I've been present
for in City Hall they've said you know
welcome ladies and gentlemen so I'm not
sure about any words being banned peers
and you know well it's an advisory it
says for example migrants shouldn't be
called illegal even if they're illegal
migrants they should be called insecure
immigration status people are
undocumented but frankly if that's
illegal I can deal with that but if
they're an illegal mind they're a legal
migrant why do you care what what the
phraseology is
let me do that so when you're an asylum
Seeker come into the UK there are there
are no safe routes to come to the UK and
what the government has done is outlawed
medic criminal offense to come to the UK
as for Asylum Seekers so many Asylum
Seekers who come to the UK may be
defined as illegal migrants because of
the government passing this law which is
isn't more in other countries but they
are Asylum Seekers who go on
to become refugees many of them great
britons uh once they've secured their
stages I think that's what it may be
referring to
this I guess is that there seems to be a
lot of energy going on uh a government
level in the NHS we've seen it with you
know you can't say mothers you have to
say birthing parents all this kind of
thing and I I don't like it I don't
really understand it I don't know why
all language has to be changed just
because there is a minority of people
who may or may not be offended by not
being included in every terminology
ultimately a mum wants to be called a
mum a dad wants to be called a dad a man
wants to be called a man a woman wants
to be called a woman a boy a boy a kid
you know a girl a girl why do we have to
have all this gender-neutral language
brought in which stops all those words
being used in officialdon why can't we
just keep it the way it was and if
people don't like it well okay I'm sorry
but you're not going to get everything
you want in life
yeah I suspect some of the reasons for
people being cognizant about the
consequences of a language is how it's
received and so I grew up at a time
where it was common for people like me
to be called the p word
or for black people to be called the
n-word or my Jewish friends to be called
the Y word and and we now accept we used
to call it them people would criticize
that call it politically correct uh but
that political correctness led to you
know me feeling a safe space to go out
and about literally a safe space but
also because London London is so
brilliant they've elected someone like
me an ethic minority and a religious
minority to be their mayor so this this
inclusivity does lead to progress in
many many ways but I accept sometimes it
can be ridiculous I was told recently
that somebody can't use the word
Blackboard because that may be offensive
too black person other a black person
offended by it that of course they're
offended as a Muslim
no but also as a Muslim I I regularly
send Christmas cards in fact I have a
Christmas art competition every year as
a member of parliament so I don't say
seasons greetings I say happy Christmas
self did I think it's you've actually
said in the past
there you go there you go probably even
after you've beastly towards me
a couple of quick ones before I let you
go uh the American presidential election
I've got Vivek ramaswami on who's the
rising star of the Republican party did
very well in the debate uh last week
he's on the show tonight what's your
view of him
well let me tell your viewers an
exclusive which I've never told you
pierce but but you were there so you'll
know this in 2016 when I was a baby male
you interviewed me with Susanna Reid on
your morning breakfast program and off
there I said to you what you think about
uh the Republican primaries and this guy
Trump running and you said to me off
there Trump's going to win and
everyone's saying there's no chance
Trump was going to win so I had a
question for you afterwards off offer
maybe or on there who do you think is
going to win but I think it's
fascinating this guy I mean anybody who
when you get to our age peace wants to
rap Eminem you know deserves you know
for doing so uh the fact that Eminem I
don't like it is his plan
a little bit of rap yourself or not
no matter though you boys were singing
Vanilla Ice on on Sunday rice rice baby
at the Arsenal yesterday
uh but no listen I'm not my daughter to
be mortified I I'm forbidden to go on
Strictly and forbidden to dance in uh
but this guy listen I may not agree with
what he's saying but the good thing
about him he is he appears authentic and
he's not a politician uh I know Trump
wasn't a politician but sometimes you've
got to shake things up in relation to
saying you know calling a spade a spade
being challenging and so forth so you
know being frank you'll be surprised to
know don't agree with this politics but
I think it's right and proper that
during a primary during a nomination
process you really do test all the
candidates and you remember how the
wheels came off some of the Republican
favorites in 2016 when Trump entered the
the race and I bet you uh you know Vivek
Ram Swami is going to upset quite a few
of the established uh candidates well
I'm sure I'm sure he will but of course
by far the front runner in the
Republican race remains Donald Trump you
and he have got a pretty check in
history to put it mildly you've allowed
a big a balloon of him as a baby to fly
over Westminster when he came into town
he's been pretty scathing about you how
would you feel if he is re-elected
president of the United States
just to get full context I also allowed
a balloon of me with a bikini to fly in
London
it could have been what it's going to be
me in person with a bikini what sauce
were the goose but can I say this is my
problem with Trump I've got a number of
problems with with President Trump and
you know I've discussed this in the past
is
how I felt how I felt
uh when he says some of the things about
the religion that I follow how my family
felt in America proud Americans proud
Muslims about what he said about women I
know how they felt when he was elected
but you'll have seen what happened on
Capitol Hill uh you know when you know
listen there's losing with dignity being
magnanimous in uh defeat and what
happened at Capitol Hill for those who
were agnostic or not sure should be the
final straw in relation to his Fitness
for uh office this is this is America
for goodness sake you know you and I are
big fans of West Wing we look to America
as a beacon for democracy human rights
separation of powers uh you know so
forth the checks and balances and I
think sometimes you know yes challenge
is good debate is good but sometimes
people are not fit for office and I
frankly don't think I don't want to
cause offense to your American views and
stuff I do not think Donald Trump is fit
to be the president of that great
country I mean should somebody who's
facing nearly a hundred criminal charges
just on basic principle should they be
allowed to be a candidate for president
as the Constitution stands at the moment
he is allowed to be he could be
president and be in prison
can I say one of the wonderful things in
the joys of America is due process and I
think it's right that Donald Trump has
his day or days in court I think there
is a presumption of innocence uh there's
a separate discussion about whether
somebody who's Presumed Innocent should
be barred from Office you know I I think
as a form of human rights lawyer that
may be unfair you're charged with an
offense not found guilty a he later or
may be acquitted I think there's a
separate discussion about uh about that
if he was for argument's sake if Trump
was convicted of a criminal defense
before the election what would your
position be then
what will surely surely then you'd
expect the the the the uh you know
there'd be provision where he's not
allowed to stand with a conviction
particularly if it's a conviction to do
with what happened on Capitol Hill
particularly if it's to do the
conviction in relation to a dishonesty
and so if there is to be a lawyer
appears if you've got even a minor
conviction for dishonesty the Law
Society doesn't allow you to be a lawyer
right because you're you're treating
you've got client money and so forth and
so forth you know and so I think you
know the president of the United States
is is not not arguably it probably is
definitely is the most powerful person
in uh the world the idea something with
a conviction can be leader of the
country Beggars believe but also let me
see the problem what message does that
send to people across the great country
of America and around the globe in
relation to no consequences for your
action and one of the great things about
Justice is its ability to deter others
what message does it send to a future
president in in relation to how they can
behave or not behave if not withstanding
all the things I've said if Capitol Hill
isn't in itself a bar from being a
future president by one of the great
things about America and we've got to
recognize this is that by the way
America did correct itself in relation
to not only the various charges you're
talking about but also the American
people deciding to you know boot Trump
out of office and bring in president uh
Biden so you know good countries with
separation of powers with good
constitutions with the Democracy in the
end you know right does overcome uh
wrong uh and I generally you know think
that you know you know Donald Trump is
not a fit person to be present of that
great country and for different reasons
given the state of him right now do you
feel comfortable if Joe Biden was to
serve another four years as president
given how often he currently Falls over
in public and gets his words wrong and
looks like he doesn't know what day it
is
well look you know I I want to say the
reputation of America
you know the moment after President
Biden was elected was hugely enhanced in
relation to how they perceived uh you've
seen you know better than I do uh that
some of the legislation has passed the
inflation reduction Act is leading to a
stimulus yeah I'm talking more about
talking more about his own lack of
apparent physical stimulus that he just
doesn't seem physically or mentally up
to the task of being president the most
powerful job in the world and there's
still another year and a half to the
election and then if he was to win
another four years in office I don't
think any rational person looks at Joe
Biden at the moment and thinks that
would be a good thing for the Free World
I I'm sending it on top of uh you know
President Biden's medical uh condition
uh but I tell you this there are some
days when I see our prime minister
performing well I think he didn't up to
the job either
I mean some of the decisions he makes I
mean come on he should have sacked you
in Keegan you showed me that video If I
Was soon act now and you showed me that
video of Jillian Keegan I'd be demanding
she'd be kicked out would you you know
his decision to yeah he was the
chancellor he was a chancellor who
decided as Chancellor to reject the
advice of the occasion secretary and cut
the school's budget by a half that was
going into repairing the schools and
spent half that budget instead are an
ideological free schools uh project and
so and those chicks coming home to roost
final question Mr may I know you've been
very generous of your time but uh recent
studies showed that there have been more
than 300
000 racist messages about you since you
became mayor in 2016 and that number has
increased exponentially since the ulez
uh story has played out and you've said
that you've had PTSD from some of this
abuse This Racist abuse you've been
suffering we had the founder of Pimlico
plumbers Charlie Mullins banned from
Twitter now called X after writing
racist and threatening comments about
you referencing the fact you're a Muslim
mayor and saying that you should be you
should be killed someone should kill him
how did you feel when you read that from
such a high profile person
I I want to say Beggar's belief
um nothing surprises me anymore
a small the impact of my daughters you
know you you you're on the receiving end
of of some of this stuff as well and so
and you know as a dad you worry about
your kids right or you know I don't know
how they are and as my daughter's seeing
that that upset me the most
um you know my wife's an adult you know
she's you know she's you know she's seen
some of the stuff but but also when you
say this stuff even though you might say
you don't mean it how do you know how
somebody else is going to react to it in
relation to you know the phenomenon of
grooming being radicalized incitement
and so listen I'm up for robust debate I
think it's really important in democracy
people should be acting in a way that
make their views clear but it should be
lawful peaceful and safe and that's one
of the reasons by the way I'm like you I
support you know the ends in relation to
just oil and existing Rebellion I don't
I don't support some of their tactics
because they're not lawful safe and
peaceful but this goes on the other side
of that because you're inciting others
to not just commit criminal offense
but to kill me I mean you know I was
somebody who was close friends with you
know Joe Cox who was murdered in 2016 I
mean you know we were close and so and
you've you know from the work you do
people across the globe who are often
the receiving end when people act on
these sorts of message and listen you've
challenged me during this interview and
and you will confirm nothing was off
balance in relation to the challenge
that's the joy of a democracy yeah I
agree but in inciting people inciting
people to create criminal offenses can
make criminal damage I think come on I
mean you know save somebody did behave
in a way
that you know uh brings to life uh what
people like that are saying and I'm at
the receiving end or say you're creating
an environment
where my ethnicity and my religion is a
relevant issue uh and I just think you
know we live in a a Multicultural
multi-racial Society
um the great thing about our country and
our city is there is no ceiling bomb
which you can't go through forget the
glass ceiling being smashed it was
decimated ages ago and you're just doing
back some of the progress making I just
I'd implore people yes be a critical of
me sign petitions go on demos you know
don't vote for me if you don't want to
vote for me and stuff but there's got to
be a line you know beyond magician
across no I completely agree with you
it's disgusting uh and to you know
Mullins has apologized since then he's
been taken off Twitter which is good
good to see Elon musk's uh Twitter X's
it now is uh taking action to take him
off for that because that's unacceptable
and I'm glad he has apologized for it um
just want to leave on a positive note Mr
Mayor you've just committed 135 million
pounds of funding meaning that 287 000
more State primary school children in
London will get free School meals from
this week that is a great thing to do
and I congratulate you on it
thanks I was somebody who had the
benefit of free School meals it was
means tested when I was young I gave my
parents breathing space
it was a Lifeline to them in relation to
knowing their kids would eat a decent
null during the course of the day but I
still remember now I don't remember what
I ate I don't remember you know that my
parents feeling relieved but I remember
the embarrassment appears because it's
means tested and so I was in a different
queue to get my token I'd see eat
separately from my mates because I was
receiving free School uh Mills and so
the good news about this policy which
children receiving benefits from today
is child getting children getting
nutrition nutrition nutritious meals at
least a better attainment in the
classroom
greater productivity in schools parents
being relieved but also it means there's
no Stigma and no shame and I'm
incredibly proud of making history the
first time in that great City's history
every child in primary school will have
a decent nutritional meal that's great
we've got a picture I think of you and
your brothers actually which uh you put
up okay all sweet I'm the good looking
fresh face I'm the I'm the good looking
one in the center
I'm sure that like my brothers they
might take issue with that but I think
it's great okay and and finally Arsenal
hammered Manchester United yesterday are
we now all agreed that North London is
red
so let's can I share with your views
exclusively that there are six clubs in
the Premier League in uh London and so
it's good as all good South londoners I
support Liverpool and I'm looking
forward to your boys getting spanked by
our boys when you come to anfield like
you always do peers but on a serious
note what we agree on is the joy in
United against beaten I think we have
recently I totally agree
if you saw his interview afterwards oh
my God I mean it's just great to watch
it's a joy to watch it was a joy to
watch uh Mr Mayor it's good to have you
on Facebook and I said so don't leave us
alone next time
I promise I won't people want to hear
your views you're a very powerful figure
in this country you run our great
capital city and it's good to have a
robust exchange really over a number of
issues thank you for joining me
stay well take care mate